madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal le camps de vacances fermés pour
graves irrégularités dans le morbihan
serait un mouvement sectaire
la communauté du sacré-coeur fondée par
un prêtre intégriste se défend aux etats
unis general motors condamnés à des
indemnités record 30 milliards de francs
pour les victimes défigurée par leurs
brûlures après un accident de voiture
à berlin un million de personnes pour la
love parade la fête de la techno et de
l'amour pour cette parade aux allures de
carnaval
et puis une page spéciale consacrée au
festival d'aix-en-provence pour cette
51e édition le pari du renouveau avec la
décentralisation des spectacles qui
prennent la clé des champs au programme
notamment la flûte enchantée et la belle
hélène et bien évidemment dans
l'actualité de ce samedi les départs en
vacances une journée classée rouge bison
futé avait vu juste dès l'aube les
premiers embouteillages qui se sont
amplifiées tout au long de la journée
au total près de 150 km de bouchons sur
les routes de france avec une
circulation en accordéon dans la vallée
du rhône
le point avec virginie ficher belgique
bonjour
sa fille à l'heure des grands départs
pour isabelle aussi la journée commence
tôt et avec le sourire
elle est le témoin obligé dulong
déroulement de la chenille estivale les
vacanciers passent isabelle reste sur le
bord du chemin des vacances sans regret
que les gens râlent - quand en tirer
merci au revoir des gens râlent - quand
c'est des départs en vacances quand ils
vont travailler vente est bien dans les
voitures ils sont partis au petit jour
où ont roulé toute la nuit avant
d'échouer ici au coeur des bouchons de
l'été pensez toujours en accordéon
il sort du lot mais c'est bien au plus
fort de la matinée le péage de
villefranche sur saône a absorbé 15 km
de bouchons même constat au péage de
vienne sur l'a7 25 km de blocage aux
heures de pointe
et cette année ici les vacanciers sont
encore plus nombreux les difficultés
rencontrées et deux premiers week-ends
viennent d'une très forte augmentation
trafic qui en principe est une
augmentation de 2 à 3% et qui depuis
deux semaines est plutôt entre 7 à 8%
régulièrement et pouvoir aller avec des
pointes de 20 à 30%
toute la journée le franchissement de
valence est resté le plus critique vers
18h enfin le fruit s'est éclaircie après
le rouge
la nuit sera verte et ce soir tous les
trains au départ de la gare de lyon à
paris accuse un retard de 2 à 3 heures
suite à un acte de malveillance sur une
installation électrique dans le morbihan
le camps de vacances fermés mercredi
pour irrégularités serait bien une
communauté intégriste qu'un rapport à
classer comme mouvements sectaires
l'évêque de troyes avait déjà mis en
garde les fidèles de son des seize
contre ces pratiques qu'il juge
contraire à la fois il s'agit de celle
préconisée par un prêtre intégriste
l'abbé georges de nantes qui a fondé la
communauté du sacré-coeur mise en
question aujourd'hui gilles marie mai
de la chapelle un chant religieux se
répand sur un lieu déserté le camp de
vacances est fermé et propriétaire
membres de la communauté du sacré-coeur
organisation considérée comme une secte
par un rapport parlementaire s'estiment
victimes de leurs convictions
en fait rien dans le fonctionnement du
camp ne correspondait aux règles en
vigueur
mais la règle commune ce n'est pas le
premier souci de cette communauté qui
siège ici à st paraissent les vaudes
dans l'aube
soixante religieux et religieuses
quelques milliers de sympathisants des
croyants intégristes en dissidence avec
rome et qui interprète toute ingérence
dans leurs affaires comme une agression
il ya quelque chose de pas normal c'est
pas normal c'est de ce prix actionnaires
nous sommes telles des genres de
l'ancienne religion et que tous assad
était un ensemble de gens qui veulent
notre disparition alors c'est une secte
nous sommes ébahis des comme siècle par
le gouvernement par l'assemblée
nationale
on nous a jamais parlé de star n'est
jamais venu enquêter chez nous et a beau
jour on était déclaré l'agencé dans le
monde entier nous sommes parmi les
sectes dangereuses
le directeur de conscience par les
adeptes pris dans le silence et quand il
lit ce sont des oeuvres choisies un
certain passé est très présent dans la
bibliothèque
pétri d'extrême droite le mouvement ne
se prie d'aucun moyen pour diffuser sa
pensée
il est également soupçonné d'appartenir
aux sectes millénaristes qui prophétise
la fin du monde au village ensemble
découvrir ses voisins installés depuis
1963 week-end on voit beaucoup de
voitures sur le trottoir mais bon c'est
parce que personne ne sait plus personne
n'en parle
c'est pas ce sujet de conversation du
village les autorités religieuses ont
pourtant mis en garde les fidèles contre
des pratiques qualifie de contraire à la
foi catholique
rien qui ne semble troubler l'abbé
georges de nantes autoproclamé entre
autres dernier prophète des temps
vous vous souvenez peut-être de la
sphère turquin ce vétérinaire niçois
condamné à 20 ans de prison pour le
meurtre de son fils aujourd'hui la
défense estime avoir les preuves que
l'enfant disparu il ya plus de huit ans
est en fait vivant installé en israël un
témoin clé s'est présenté à la pj de
nice
yasmina farber diane richard ici qu'à
raconter son histoire aux enquêteurs de
la police judiciaire de nice
ce jeune religieux membre d'une
association qui recherchent notamment
des enfants disparus
issus de mariages mixtes a accepté de
partir sur les traces de charles edouard
turquin en israël mars 91
l'enfant de 8 ans disparaît alors qu'il
dort au côté de son père jean-louis turc
invs a avoué son meurtre à sa femme elle
le piège sur bande magnétique
pas de cadavre mais une intime
conviction des jurés jean-louis turquin
repart condamné à 20 ans prison mais
selon ethic
un jeune homme de 16 ans correspond au
profil de charles-edouard il vit dans
une école rabbinique de tibériade
il m'a confié qu'il lui manquait une
partie de sa vie il ne connaissait ni sa
mère is over donc nos iphone
et family date et la famille qui
s'occupe de lui lui a dit que sa mère
n'était pas achevée et que donc il ne
pouvait pas l'avoir c'est une semaine
plus tard je lui ai montré ses photos il
les a regardés très vite
puis il m'a dit qu'il ne voulait pas les
voir c'est cette histoire lui faisait
peur des indices mais pas de preuve
définitive pourtant l'avocat du
vétérinaire est confiant il s'interroge
sur l'attitude de michel ballanger jeudi
qu'une mère à qui on n'apprend que son
enfant de la justice a considéré comme
ayant été assassinés serait encore en
vie aujourd'hui devraient se précipiter
avec une joie folle devant les autorités
de police et les autorités judiciaires
pour essayer à tout près de retrouver
cet enfant normal estime ses avocats il
démystifie cette piste israélienne elle
a échoué dans le cadre d'une enquête qui
avait été ordonnée par le président de
la cour d'assises avant que la sphère de
vienne pour être jugé et qui ensuite
alors tomber complètement à plat
lors de lors du procès cette étrange
feuilleton judiciaire intéresse de près
les autorités israéliennes la justice
française va leur communiquer
l'intégralité du dossier turc un
politique avec ses déclarations plutôt
sévère de valéry giscard d'estaing
l'égard du président de la république
dans les colonnes du monde
il engage jacques chirac a instauré le
quinquennat au plus vite et lui
conseille donc d'abréger son septennat
en provoquant l'an 2000 la prochaine
élection présidentielle
valéry giscard d'estaing qui critique au
passage la cohabitation
aux etats unis ces indemnités record le
premier groupe automobile américain
condamné à payer 5 milliards de dollars
aux victimes d'un accident de la route
défigurée par leurs brûlures
jean-bernard chute
alisha anderson est marqué dans sa chair
depuis l'accident qu'elle a vécu c'était
il ya six ans sur une route de
californie hier soir un tribunal a
décidé d'en faire un exemple historique
il a en effet condamné de general motors
premier groupe automobile américain à
verser 30 milliards de francs de
dommages et intérêts aux victimes
ce n'est pas une question d'argent nous
envoyons un message à general motors
parce qu'il y à d'autres personnes
d'autres familles qui sont dans le même
cas que nous en décembre 1993 le
véhicule d anderson avait pris feu après
avoir été violemment heurtée à l'arrière
alors qu'il attend d'être un carrefour
pour obtenir réparation
leur avocat a estimé que sur ce modèle
de voiture le réservoir était trop près
du pare chocs et à l'appui de sa
démonstration une étude secrète d'un
ingénieur de general motors qui
estimaient en 1973 que les éventuels
mort par incendie coûterait moins cher
au constructeur que de faire modifier
les véhicules
nous avons produit devant un tribunal
des documents et des nattes montrant que
general motors a littéralement comparer
le prix d'une vie humaine à ses membres
une mesure de sécurité
dès l'annoncé du verdict general motors
a décidé de faire appel du jugement
s'il était confirmé les dommages et
intérêts de 30 milliards de francs
pourraient absorber la quasi totalité
des réserves en liquidités du groupe
automobile au kosovo les informations
concernant la découverte d'un charnier
comprenant 350 victimes restent pour
l'instant à confirmer
l' enquête se poursuit les données sont
incertaines à vrai dire il serait
davantage question de massacres
concentré dans cette région à l'ouest du
kosovo que deux charniers à proprement
parler sur place nos envoyés spéciaux
agnès vahramian et nathalie gallet ont
tenté d'approcher les lieux les images
de ce reportage sont difficiles lioubé
nietzsche est un petit village des
alentours de pécs avant la guerre disent
ses habitants de 1000 personnes y
vivaient la kfor annoncé hier avoir
découvert ici un charnier de 350 corps
ça aurait été le plus important du
kosovo mais voilà cette information
s'est avéré inexact
ayoub et nietzsche toutes les maisons
portent les stigmates de violence pas
une qui n'ait été incendiés et pillés
mais de charlier de la terre retournée
avec trois cent cinquante cadavres
aucune trace cet habitant le raconte que
six jours après le début de l'offensive
de l'otan
la milice herbe d'arcane a rassemblé une
cinquantaine de personnes à cet endroit
en bas du village
les paramilitaires ont tiré lui a été
laissé pour mort une balle dans le pied
il a pu s'échapper en rampant à quelques
mètres dans la cour de cette maison il
nous montre des restes humains
les corps de personnes exécutées traîner
ici par les chiens pense-t-il
puis plus loin des siècles de cendres
ans le garçon au total pour les
villageois les paramilitaires ont tenter
ainsi de faire disparaître leurs actions
il y a quelques jours un enquêteur du
tribunal pénal international s'est
déplacé sur le site sans pratiquer
aucune investigation mais en donnant la
consigne de ne toucher à rien
pourtant la tentation est forte pour les
villageois de chercher des éléments
d'identité des victimes un récit
descendre mais toujours pas de charnier
cet autre homme affirme avoir rejoint
les flancs de la montagne qui surplombe
le village de l'offensive
une centaine de femmes et d'hommes
étaient avec lui pour chasser par les
serbes essuyant des tirs trébuchant
aussi dans les ravins ils témoignent
avoir retrouvé 27 corps dans la forêt
ces jours derniers le chiffre de 350
cadavre dans un même lieu n'est
confirmée ni par les habitants de loubet
nietzsche qui cherchent toujours leur
mort ni par les italiens de la kfor de
pécs qui disent ne pas être à l'origine
de l'information c'est qu'on fait la
connaissance d'une patrouille ici que tu
sors sont pas le dire mais brûler sans
rien provoc dans ce secteur tenu par les
italiens de la kfor les militaires ont
découvert 22 sites contenant pense-t-il
les corps de six cents personnes
l'enquêteur du tribunal pénal
international présent ici et à qui ils
ont transmis ses informations recueille
aujourd'hui des témoignages pour définir
sur quel site
les crimes de guerre auraient été commis
mais son travail ne fait que commencer
en iran cette vague de contestation qui
a amené des milliers d'étudiants dans
les rues de téhéran qui protestent
contre la décision de fermer un journal
réformateur
de violents affrontements entre
militants intégristes des jeunes se
déroulent depuis plusieurs jours le
ministre de l'enseignement a démissionné
dénonçant les violences policières
situation de crise prend ce jeudi
ce matin ils se sont retrouvés par
milliers devant la principale université
de téhéran
ces étudiants crié mort au dictateur
à bas le despotisme honte aux forces de
l'ordre
cette manifestation s'en prend aux
conservateurs du régime de téhéran
après les violents affrontements entre
forces de l'ordre et étudiants jeudi
dernier alors que ces jeunes
protestaient contre la fermeture d'un
journal salam favorables ou président
réformateur khatami
les forces de l'ordre et des miliciens
islamistes réprimés dans le sang
ces manifestations et cette mère pleure
son fils tués dans les violences qui
auraient fait au moins trois victimes
parmi les étudiants
et c'est peut-être une crise politique
majeure qu'affronte aujourd'hui la
république des mollahs
ces étudiants sont les plus fidèles
alliés du président rabbani dans la
lutte qu'il mène contre les
conservateurs du régime de téhéran
les universités s'enflamme comme on ne
l'avait jamais vu depuis la naissance de
la république islamique
des coups de boutoir contre un régime en
crise à sept mois d'élections
législatives décisives à berlin le
rendez vous des amoureux de l'amour et
de la techno pour la love parade un
milieu de fans d'un million de fans pour
cette immense cortège qui déambulent
depuis le début d'après midi en plein
centre de la capitale allemande sur
place olivier lerner c'est comme si une
onde de choc traverse et berlin de part
en part
c'est l'amour pas la guerre qui les
rassemblent dans ce vacarme
indescriptible
david arrive tout droit de paris la love
parade c'est une première pour lui
florence à berlin depuis trois ans est
bien dans la couleur locale
devancée de musique la clé de voir la
communication de l'amour de la rencontre
ça veut aussi dire et je veux dire on a
pas d'amour sans parce que les gars se
montrent plus une communication qui
passe par des cris des sifflets des
mouvements du corps emportés par une
musique techno un peu répétitive n'est
pas désagréable au fond
on avance on ne s'entend plus près des
chars qui arrose le tout dit de décibels
c'est la communication verbale n'existe
plus alors il faut employer d'autres
moyens pour nous et compte pas mariés la
parade est sur toutes les chaînes de
télévision allemandes
ils n'étaient qu'une poignée en 1989
les créateurs de la love parade ont fait
fortune avec ce concept simple de
l'amour porté par une musique rythmique
quitté boum boum dans les coeurs et
vibrer les deux rounds mais cette love
parade et veut être la dernière à berlin
les organisateurs estiment en effet
qu'ils n'ont plus tout à fait les mains
libres pour commercialiser cet événement
paris pourrait servir de relais de
l'année prochaine près de paris à
l'hippodrome de longchamp solidarité
musique pour deux jours de concert
presque non-stop au profit de la lutte
contre le sida solidays devrait
rassembler quelque 60000 spectateurs
aujourd'hui demain ambiance de fête sur
scène et sur la pelouse dès le premier
spectacle pierre emmanuel luneau mahdi
diawara voici le résultat d'une très
bonne idée surtout ne pas banaliser le
sida deux jours de concerts trois scènes
60000 spectateurs attendus et surtout la
présence de dizaines d'associations pour
en mettre mou se protéger
non mais vous avez écrit
de préservatifs
je sais pas
1 2 3 4 5 6
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup peut-être trop
certainement pas mais tous les jeunes
festivaliers ne sont pas aussi sérieux
et pour les associations il ne faut pas
baisser la garde
il ya une démobilisation des gens par
rapport à l'épidémie ya abusivement ça
fait partie des nombreuses idées fausses
sur le sida ya beaucoup de gens qui
estiment
presque que c'est fini alors pour ne pas
s'endormir face au risque toujours
présent solidays a choisi la musique
bonne nouvelle là dedans c'est qu'il ya
plein de gens de jeunes des 15-25 qui
qui viennent et qui montrent par leur
présence ici
nous n'en sommes plus à la musique mais
qui sont pas à se mobiliser et agir dans
le sens de cette fameuse solidarité
vente au sujet de laquelle on parle des
paroles des musiques
un mélange qui fera vibrer l'hippodrome
de longchamp jusqu'à dimanche soir
inauguration ce matin de l'armada du
siècle sous le soleil et le regard
ébloui de dizaines de milliers de
personnes la parade des gréements et des
navires de guerre
déjà un immense succès pour cette
manifestation qui devrait se poursuivre
tout au long de la semaine à venir
reportage tirer curtet olivier robert
quatre cent mille spectateurs hier à
coup sûr beaucoup plus aujourd'hui
la fête est gratuite les quais bondés le
spectacle est autant sur l'eau que dans
les airs de la ligne de flottaison ou
chaumet du grand mas il ya souvent plus
de 50 mètres pour les bateaux
sud-américains ou polonais et les grands
trois-mâts habitué aux manifestations
publiques ça à faire le spectacle
chaque public y trouve son compte pour
certains c'est l'histoire de la voile
pour d'autres ce serait plutôt les
histoires de marins elles savent
d'ailleurs joué les enjôleuse et passe
devant tout le monde
dans les files d'attentes
viens voir les magnifiques voiliers puis
c'est tellement agréable de voir grand
et beau soleil
pour le quarté mox et 275 hommes
d'équipage dont 100 cadet est l'un des
plus visités et il n'y a que le pont
supérieur d'accessible alors on se tord
le cou pour en avoir un peu plus
les gens et oui à travers du tour
les amarrages les gauches et puis bah
pour les autres bateaux et le métissage
des cultures grands
lui est un peu plus mal un peu plus
passionnés aussi que les autres jambes
riche préside un jury d'élégance depuis
qu'il est à la retraite
après une demi heure de palabres il va
pouvoir visiter les salons intérieur le
trois-mâts mexicain est selon lui le
plus beau bateau dû migrer absolument
parfait mais aussi une très grande
relation entre les salons de pointe est
mort son petit salon c'est avec
l'histoire du pays c'est ça qui fait la
richesse de bateaux 1 c'est ce qui fait
la richesse du bateau parce que c'est un
polar du pays
le luxueux quoi tu évoques doit son nom
aux derniers empereurs aztèques pour
sans doute la plupart des visiteurs de
l'armada c'est gigantesque cathédrale de
voile la garderont une bonne part de
leur mystère mais ils seront nombreux à
l'avoir approché de très près
le tour de france avec pour la quatrième
fois en quatre jours la victoire de
l'italien mario cipollini c'est le
premier coureur depuis 1947 à réaliser
un tel exploit
un parcours sans faute pour cette
septième étape nathanaël de rincquesen
mario cipollini est bien le meilleur
sprinteur du monde
à thionville l'italien remporté sa
quatrième victoire consécutive sur le
tour au terme d'un sprint encore une
fois spectaculaires regardez bien
l'allemand erik zabel
avec son maillot vert on a frôlé la
chute collective à 70 km heure
cet après midi lylian lebreton a bien
failli offrir à la france sa première
victoire le coureur de l'équipe big mat
auber échappé pendant 200 kilomètres a
compté près de dix minutes d'avancé
rejoint par jacky durand un autre
français lylian lebreton a échoué à
seulement 4 kilomètres de la ligne
d'arrivée à thionville
il ya une pièce i put a sans doute ont
pilé pour la dernière fois le maillot
jaune demain l'épreuve contre-la-montre
devrait apporter de nombreux changements
en tête du classement général
aux etats unis la coupe du monde de
football féminin suscite des passions
dévorantes les adolescentes vous
désormais un véritable engouement voir
un véritable culte à ces sportifs qui
sont devenus leurs stars de référence
dans moins de deux heures en californie
se déroulera la finale l'équipe
américaine contre l'équipe chinoise
une rencontre à guichets fermés
dominique derda leur nom leur visage ne
vous dit sans doute rien et le sport
qu'elle pratique quand il se conjugue au
féminin en europe la plupart du temps
fait sourire les virils amateurs
et bien dans ce pays lorsque l'équipe
nationale se produit sur un terrain il
leur est plus une place dans les gradins
on attend ce soir 92 mille personnes au
rose bowl de pasadena pour la finale de
la coupe du monde qui opposera les états
unis à la chine
du jamais vu et si l'immense majorité de
ses supporters enthousiastes sont des
supportrices c'est parce que le football
ici est un sport de filles pour les
filles c'est quelque chose de nouveau et
cette coupe du monde les passionne
vraiment ya tant d'autres sports où ce
sont les hommes qui dominent équipes
masculines bien rares sont celles ou
ceux qui se souviennent du nom d'un seul
joueur
en revanche toute l'amérique connaît
celui de mis à rames ne garde jamais la
balle pour elle toute seule elle est
trop bonne elle marque un but allait
rapide elle a toutes les qualités
jusqu'à bill clinton qui soudainement
s'est laissé séduire et assistera à
cette rencontre au sommet dont ils
espèrent qu'elle permettra d'améliorer
les relations diplomatiques entre les
deux pays au plus mal depuis le
bombardement de l'ambassade de chine à
belgrade
et dire qu'il y a huit ans à peine
lorsque son équipe féminine remportait
sa première finale de coupe du monde
l'amérique avait accueilli la nouvelle
dans la plus grande indifférence
je vous propose maintenant cette page
spéciale consacrée ce soir au festival
d'aix-en-provence et sans plus attendre
nous retrouvons tout de suite bruno alma
d'habitude vous vous trouviez dans le
coeur de la vieille ville et apparemment
là vous aider la campagne oui bonsoir
béatrice est bienvenu disons à une
petite dizaine de kilomètres au nord
d'aix
parce que le festival international de
musique s'offre un petit séjour à la
campagne vous savez c'est très à la mode
depuis qu'en angleterre on a pris
l'habitude d'aller pique-niquer avant de
se rendre à l'opéra notamment au
festival de glyndebourne
cela dit si le festival d'aix
s'installent à la campagne et dans cette
magnifique bastide du xviie siècle
c'est tout simplement pour offrir un
nouveau lieu au public aux artistes et
pouvoir présenter des spectacles avec
une tarification un peu plus accessible
mais qu'on ne s'y trompe pas les
standards les exigences musicales du
festival de musique d'aix restent les
mêmes et pour vous rassurer béatrice
soyez tranquilles on pourra toujours
aller assister au spectacle dans la cour
de la de l'archevêché dans le
centre-ville mais je l'espère bien en
tout cas l'événement tout à l'heure si
la première représentation de la flûte
enchantée de mozart une production
originale dans un nouveau théâtre en
plein air celui là dirigée par david
stern un reportage marielle ngono jean
louis moulin rémy poissonnier
stéphane braunschweig le stress d'avant
la représentation pour le metteur en
scène et ses héros voici papageno un
esclave
tamino la reine
et sa fille la jolie pamina tout est
prêt au grand saint jean pour un voyage
enchanté sous la direction musicale de
david stern
mais
oh
m
l'émotion est là toute la beauté de
l'opéra de mozart dans un décor
volontairement tu es tout
seuls six colonnes de téléviseurs
restituent des images ce parcours à
travers les images vidéo
c'est un parcours un peu de l'autre côté
du miroir mais de l'autre côté du côté
du rêve et et et en même temps ça
fonctionne aussi comme des toiles
peintes comme comme un théâtre à
l'ancienne
une histoire d'amour entre terminaux et
plats mina qui donneront traversé bien
des épreuves avant de pouvoir s'aimer ce
sera le triomphe de la lumière sur la
nuit représentée par la reine
un conte lyrique sur le passage de
l'enfance à l'âge adulte évoqué avec des
images vidéo en hommage aux côtés du dit
de l'oeuvre de monet
mon noël bat vous êtes à présent sur
scène et les musiciens qui seront à
l'oeuvre tout à l'heure sont de tout
jeunes artistes
oui vous savez béatrice depuis l'an
dernier ce festival fait souffler un peu
de vent frais sur les nouveaux talents
et c'est le but notamment de l'académie
européenne de musique et que stephen
d'isner souhaité et a finalement créé
dès l'année dernière les musiciens et
les chanteurs surtout ont commencé à
travailler ce que vous avez vu tout à
l'heure dans la flûte enchantée ont
commencé à travailler pour cette
représentation de cette année et ceux de
cette année sont d'ores et déjà en train
de travailler avec de grands anciens en
vue de préparer les spectacles de
l'année prochaine c'est un reportage
vous allez le voir de notre ami michel
mompontet avec rémy poissonnier
ode à un rendez vous elle va vivre elle
le sait une de ces rencontres qui
peuvent éclairer la route d'une jeune
musicien l'après midi durant en effet
isaac stern et ses 60 ans de musique
ils ont compté pour elle le plus que
tous les publics de sa carrière à venir
elle a toujours besoin d'être d'abri des
on a toujours besoin d'avoir des
oreilles extérieur et les oreilles
extérieur comme celle des vaccins c'est
une grande chance il n'y a pas assez d
années dans une vie oh divine et tous
les possibilités de chaque phrase là
toujours quelque chose à apprendre
parce que tous ces jeunes musiciens sont
déjà maîtres de leur club
il ne s'agit pas ici de gamme ni de
techniques et seulement ce petit
supplément d'âme que je t en play offs
si vous n'êtes pas disciplinés vous
n'êtes pas libres parce que ce sont eux
mêmes de discipline qu'on peut trouver
la liberté quand on aime vraiment
discipline et on peut penser que quelque
chose de faire le mig atma parc du mal
comment je dois le faire qu'est ce qu'il
a dit comment je ne sais pas quoi on
doit avoir tout ça sous contrôle et si
par bonheur sourire du maître
voilà c'est comme la récompense comme si
entre les élèves
il tente un compliment sonne comme une
promesse commission d'examen très beau
centre mais évidemment très très beau
compliment son tournant car pour lui ça
me touche beaucoup
ça me donne du courage pour continuer
la vie professionnelle de haut 2 sera
faite de millions min
mais peut-être que cette rencontre aura
colorier on peut davantage autant de
noirs
mais bruno à vos côtés nous allons
retrouver david stern qui dirige cette
flûte enchantée et nora gubisch une
jeune soprano qui pour la première fois
je sens très heureux titre delà de la
belle hélène
oui j'ai envie de commencer par david
stern
on vient me voir isaac stern c'est
facile d'être musicien quand on a eu à
coeur comme ça c'est facile d'aimer la
musique c'est facile de respirer et
vivre avec la musique c'est pas lui qui
vous a appris à devenir chef d'orchestre
du tout c'était un métier qui s'apprend
très doucement avec beaucoup de patience
et beaucoup de concentration
alors je le disais tout à l'heure ça
fait un an que vous travaillez cette
flûte enchantée avec les chanteurs c'est
des conditions exceptionnelles pour un
chef d'orchestre exceptionnel et puis
finalement qu'on a maintenant à la fin
de nos répétitions je me sens que c'est
tout à fait correct parce que c'est avec
seulement avec ce temps cette patience
et ce temps pour approfondir le travail
qu'on puisse vraiment faire quelque
chose qui tient son des musiciens
professionnels déjà en professionnel
fait un grand mot je dirai ce sont des
musiciens qui ont l'oreille qui s'écoute
qui aiment la musique qu'ils aiment
faire la musique ça c'est le plus
important
et vous êtes satisfait du résultat pour
l'instant satisfait pour l'instant je
suis content parce encore contentée mais
je suis content alors n'aura globish on
vous a vu hier soir dans la belle hélène
de jacques offenbach première question
aix-en-provence c'était une surprise
quand stéphane lissner vous est demandé
de venir chanter le rôle titre ici bah
oui c'est forcément toujours une
surprise parce que ex c'est complètement
mythique
alors quand on est une jeune chanteuse
sait
bon c'est merveilleux d'avoir la chance
de venir chanter là bon vous a déjà vu à
la bastille vous avez déjà enregistré
vous êtes vous êtes vraiment une artiste
déjà confirmée même si c'est le début de
votre carrière
quand on vous a dit la belle hélène une
opérette à aix
ouais ouais mais c'est vrai que j'étais
pas complètement une folle folle
d'offenbach parce que je connaissais pas
bien et que j'avais des petits a priori
comme beaucoup de personnes et j'ai
découvert la partition et maintenant je
m'amuse jeumont j'éprouve un grand
bonheur à chanter cette belle hélène et
vous souhaiteriez revenir d'imaginer ce
à quelques si on chantait un véritable
opéra ah oui pourquoi pas béatrice oui
bonjour moi je propose tout de suite de
voir à quoi ressemble la production de
cette belle hélène donc à ne ferra
opérette burlesque offenbach revisité
sur la moto avec ses deux copines le
dernier au reste le salon le disait lui
va servir de cadre à l'assemblée des
rois devresse une électrolyse bien dans
l'esprit de pull back qui se servait de
la mythologie brocarder le guépard et et
ses copains
les rois sont au costume de ville comme
de vrais chefs d'état moderne
au centre de la pièce la belle hélène
lm parisse et trompe en songe sens et
vous venez là ce prototype du cocu
magnifique
oui la belle hélène héroïne anti
aventurière hypermoderne chamboule tout
et ridiculise les puissants plonger dans
les situations les plus saugrenues
oh
à
e
et comme chacun le sait l enlèvement de
la reine hélène par parisse est à
l'origine de la guerre de troie
reportage signé daniel wolfromm et rémy
poissonnier avant de conclure on vous
retrouve bruno albane devant la bastide
de le grand saint jean au fond quelle
place occupera désormais la fameuse cour
de l'archevêché toujours une place
majeure béatrice est naturellement
magique vous savez cela fait 50 ans que
cette place est au coeur du festival est
au coeur de la ville et donc cette année
on pourra y reprendront ils revoir par
don le don juan de mozart mis en scène
par peter brook
la belle hélène dont nous avons parlé
avec nora gubisch est également un
magnifique cour couronnement de poppée
avec mireille delunsch et anne sofie von
otter voilà
juste une petite précision avant de vous
rendre l'antenne tous les soirs sur
mezzo qui est la chaîne câblée de france
télévision dédié à la musique
vous pourrez suivre des échos de ce
festival d'aix-en-provence
quant à moi un bien triste je ne sais
pas ce que vous faites ce soir mais pour
ma part y à mozart au programme
interviews pour vous et moi je suis à
paris vous raconterez merci bruno alba
pour cette page spéciale
ainsi se termine cette édition tout de
suite après la météo nathalie rihouet
20h50 fort boyard demain midi géopolis
de claude sérillon nous emmènera au fin
fond de la russie sur la trace de ces
colons russes considérées comme des
étrangers dans les républiques où ils
sont nés après l'éclatement de l'empiré
soviétique je vous remercie de votre
attention
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain dès 13h excellente fin de soirée
sur france 2
l'image du jour